all right we're now down to the
championship round with Oliver and odd
off' and we're starting with a clean
slate we have five questions whoever
comes up with the most correct responses
will be our 2010 National Geographic Bee
champion here is question number one
SWANA SWANA is a Bantu language spoken
by the largest ethnic group in what
landlocked country SWANA is a Bantu
language spoken by the largest ethnic
group in what landlocked country time is
up
put your cards up please Oliver you
wrote down Zambia and Edith you wrote
down
Botswana you went for the obvious you
are correct that's one point for you
question number two the production of
yerba mate a a tea made from an
evergreen plant is important to the
economy of Misiones this province is
located in which country that borders
Paraguay put your cards up we have
Bolivia for Oliver and Argentina for
Oddie's the country is Argentina that's
two points for aadhi question number
three the øresund bridge o r e s und
opened in 2000 it connects Copenhagen
Denmark with what Swedish city put your
cards up
both of you came up with the same
response and both of you are correct the
city is maluma our next question and
your grandfather's I think could come up
with a correct response to this let's
see how well you do Cam Ranh Bay has
served as a naval base for France Japan
the United States and the former Soviet
Union this Bay is located in which
country Cam Ranh Bay time is up put your
cards up ah did you were going for New
Zealand and Oliver was going for China
both of you are incorrect the correct
response is Vietnam so let's go to the
last question shall we
Haiti very much in the news this past
year the largest city in northern Haiti
was renamed following Haiti's
independence from France
what is the present-day name of this
city put your cards up Oliver wrote down
port-au-prince Adi throat down Kap ice
yeah the correct response the largest
city in northern Haiti is cap a shame
Ardeth congratulations young man you are
the 2010 National Geographic campus
Oliver second place well done young man
well done back thank you and now the
check for $25,000 and the other goodies
as well from mr. fait to ardath's Morley
from Florida lifetime membership to the
society and you have a trip to the
Galapagos Islands as well Ardeth so
congratulations
you